ja ich bin sehr schneider ich komme aus
bremen und intensivpflege auf einen den
sie stolz und bringen einige strecken
gerecht gelobt in meiner maske sammelt
sich eine karte für andreas schneider
ist sein job als intensivpfleger ein
absoluter traumberuf der menschen helfen
will war den 37 jährigen schon als kind
klar doch in einem krankenhaus für
arbeiten wird immer schwerer
nicht erst seit kurzem also die
situation allgemein ich habe ja auch
kontakt mit anderen krankenhäusern mit
kollegen auch bundesweit das auch vor
der krone zahlen natürlich die
arbeitsbelastung extrem war folgen auf
dem die sehstation war natürlich auch
personalmangel herrscht und jetzt zu
keiner zeit ist es natürlich extremer
geworden
den patienten gerecht zu werden und
jetzt akut vor zwei drei tagen fehlen
jetzt auch schon bundesweit soweit ich
das von den kollegen gehört habe
schutzkleidung die schutzkittel
handschuhen excel handschuhe und ich
frage mich vorgefühlt eineinhalb monaten
wurde von den politikern angekündigt
dass die zweite welle kommen sollte im
herbst und jetzt schon mangel oder
besteht schon mangel an schutzbekleidung
und das verstehe ich einfach nicht da
muss irgend jemand in der regierung
geschlafen haben oder sich nicht
vernünftig darauf vorbereitet haben und
das ist mein vorwurf über unter anderem
volk über dieses musikvideo
wir sind ja das ist jetzt nicht
[Musik]
keine pause heißt der song den schneider
aufgenommen hat darin geht es um die
schwere arbeit in den krankenhäusern in
der korona zeit und die gefühle des
personals dort ok also ich bin nicht
wirklich ein sänger ich bin jetzt nicht
der zweite muschel oder so aber ich
finde einfach dass ein interview von
einem klang im pflege- oder schwester
sich keiner mehr an wird in
öffentlichkeit und ich finde etwas
besonderes sollte man machen und das war
jetzt das musikvideo was man halt auch
natürlich gut teilen kannst ob es gut
oder schlecht ist aber ich glaube der
inhalt von dem text er kommt sehr gut an
jeder wird verstehen was ich damit
bezwecken möchte weil wie gesagt ein
interview plötzlich keiner mehr
angenommen würde sie auch keiner teilen
aktuell liegen auf andreas schneiders
intensivstation in der klinik links der
weser keine corona patienten
doch das kann sich angesichts der
steigenden zahlen jederzeit ändern
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren